on en vient à présent à la guerre en
Ukraine avec ses frappes à l'Ouest du
pays selon les autorités ukrainiennes
les villes de le vivre notamment et de
Lutz ont été ciblées il y aura au moins
trois morts à l'est sur le front les
combats eu font toujours rage l'Ukraine
affirme notamment avoir progressé dans
la région de barmouth le président
Zénith qui lui a rencontré les troupes
dans la région Emmanuel Chaze bonjour
vous êtes notre correspondante en
Ukraine Emmanuel frappe importante
notamment dans l'ouest du pays cette
nuit
oui tout à fait une nouvelle attaque
massive de missile la nuit passée alors
principalement dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine
mais pas seulement la ville de nitro a
été également touché donc un centre un
centre industriel un centre d'affaires a
été touché à Lutz dans l'ouest de pays
environ 85 km de la frontière polonaise
et bien il y a eu trois victimes trois
personnes décédées 9 hospitalisés suite
à des frappes sur un complexe industriel
cette fois et enfin de vivre également
proche de la frontière polonaise à
nouveau été touché avec le maire de les
vives qui affirme que plus de 100 plus
d'une centaine d'appartements ne sont
plus habitables les fenêtres ont été
complètement pulvérisées il y a
également plusieurs personnes blessées
et un missiles ou du moins les débris
d'un métier sont tombés sur un jardin
d'enfants une image tristement familière
que nous avions vécu ici à Kiev il y a
il y a environ 10 mois ici en plein cœur
de Kiev donc ces attaques sur les civils
et bien elle continue de la parure sur
l'ensemble du territoire ukrainien
Emmanuel Vladimir Zelinski le président
lucrètien lui il s'est rendu à la
rencontre des troupes sur le front
c'était dans la région de doniette mais
c'est ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'il va la rencontre des soldats
absolument cette même devenue une
habitude pour le président ukrainien de
se rendre au plus près de la ligne de
fond qu'il s'agisse de la ligne de front
s dans la région de Deniez combien près
de Zapoli j'ai hâte de mikolaief où il
s'était rendu fin juillet alors cette
fois-ci il s'est rendu dans la région de
deniers ou les forces ukrainiennes
affirment avoir reconquérir reconquis
reconquier du territoire près de la
ville de barmouth 3 km² selon la
ministre délégué à la Défense Anna
maliard et puis cette visite
présidentielle elle arrive à point car
les soldats qui font partie de cette
contre-offensive et bien ils ont vous
savez ils savent qu'ils sont en
développement page numérique il
s'agissent de personnels qui s'agissent
d'équipements il y a un troisième un
troisième facteur très important dans
cette contre-offensive c'est le moral et
le fait que leur président Vienne sur la
ligne de front distribue des médailles
mais aussi puissant tendre les doléances
et soldats et bien c'est très important
pour les troupes en l'état Vladimir
Zelenski a dit qu'il avait compris que
ces troupes manquaient d'équipements
manquait de munitions et qu'il fallait
absolument
procurer plus de drones puisque c'est
aussi sur ce terrain là et avec ce
matériel là que cette contre-offensive
va se jouer
merci beaucoup Emmanuel pour toutes ces
précisions Emmanuel chasse notre
correspondant Ukraine